évidemment la réforme des retraites va
occuper une large partie de nos échanges
aujourd'hui je vais commencer avec un
élément simple et Philippe Godin leur
rappelait dans son journal près de 7
Français sur 10 nous dit l'ifope ce
matin pour le JD sont contre la réforme
des retraites les Français monsieur
Barroux ils n'en veulent pas oui
la question est est-ce que on peut vivre
sans réforme des retraites est-ce qu'on
peut continuer
sur l'équilibre enfin le déséquilibre
actuel
est-ce que c'est vivable est-ce que
c'est durable est-ce que c'est tenable
et c'est sur ce point que je crois
vraiment que on doit faire la
démonstration précise donner des
éléments à chacun des citoyens
pour qu'ils se fasse même leur propre
opinion alors je vais vous donner des
chiffres plus ils seront moins utiles
oui parce qu'ils sont responsables
moi je crois profondément à une société
plus démocratique que j'appelle de
co-responsabilité en France depuis des
années on s'est habitué à ce que ce soit
des années des siècles on s'est habitué
à ce que ce soir
vieille culture monarchique le sommet
qui décide et la base qui subit
l'espèce c'est le cas comme il
s'agissait pas de citoyens comme s'il ne
s'agissait pas de citoyens mais de
sujets et moi je plaide c'est alors
peut-être suis idéaliste mais je veux
bien accepter d'être idéaliste je plaide
pour que on est au contraire
un travail un effort de
co-responsabilité que chacun des
citoyens et les moyens de se faire une
opinion alors je vais vous donner un
chiffre simple qui ont été établies par
le plan dans un rapport que vous avez lu
à la fin du mois de novembre au début du
mois de décembre et ce et ce rapport est
très simple les retraites les pensions
versées à tous les Français
coûte
345 milliards au système de retraite
sur ces 345 milliards l'état envers
alors que les fonctionnaires de l'État
représentent à peu près 20%
de tous les salariés et vous voyez donc
l'état ayant 20% des salariés vers plus
de 40% des ressources du système de
retraite
alors il y a des versements qui sont
absolument légitimes absolument normaux
par exemple
si les fonctionnaires sont des salariés
qui doivent avoir une retraite l'État
verse sacote pas le système de retraite
ça fait 25 milliards et Monsieur Berrou
pardon mais ces arguments ça fait
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois que le
gouvernement les 10 sur les plateaux et
bien ça ne fonctionne pas les Français
continuent à être très majoritairement
excusez-moi je ne le enfin je crois que
ces arguments n'ont pas été donnés
clairement à tous les Français la preuve
c'est qu'il y a un très grand nombre de
citoyens et de responsables qui disent
comme un mantra comme une répétition de
chaque minute qui disent mais la réforme
est
inutile et elle n'est pas urgente
puisque notre système de retraite nous
dit-on est équilibré et même certains
disent excédentaires
pas du tout
l'excédent était
de
0 enfin de 900 millions dans dans la
précédente livraison du rapport du 2021
et 2022 3,2 milliards d'euros je
les chiffres que nous avons avancés qui
sont les chiffres même du corps que le
que le que le plan a analysé que
personne n'a contredit
vous avez pas entendu une contestation
de ces chiffres ces chiffres sont que
au-delà des cotisations légitimes que je
décrivais au delà des compensations
quand l'État dit au système au régime de
retraite vous allez donner des avantages
familiaux par exemple c'est normal qu'il
compense puisque c'est lui qui décide ça
ça représente à peu près 90 milliards et
reste 30 milliards 30 milliards les
chiffres
les mots passent si vite que dans
l'impression que c'est pas beaucoup 30
milliards c'est 30 000 millions d'euros
chaque année
qui sont
versées par le contribuable
et pire encore ou plus grave encore ou
plus déterminant encore qui sont mis à
la charge de générations futures parce
qu'on les empreinte et que c'est les
générations
et qu'il faut aller à peine un peu plus
loin que ce que je viens de dire
contrairement à ce qui est avancé les
régimes ne sont pas équilibrés l'État
les subventions de plus de 30 milliards
et ce que décrivent les rapports que
vous indiquez c'est très simple c'est
que la situation va se déterminer entre
10 et 15 milliards je pousse je pousse
votre raisonnement jusqu'au bout du bout
du bout imaginons le gouvernement prend
le temps de faire la pédagogie des
semaines des mois si le faux et pourquoi
ne pas proposer ça au référendum ensuite
pourquoi ne pas dire aux Français qui ne
sont pas des sujets mais qui sont bien
des citoyens correspondables allez-y
prononcez-vous vous me prenez dans le
sens du poil parce que j'ai toujours
plaidé pour que cette réforme soit
à jour si on voulait qu'elle soit
acceptée sans difficulté la thèse que
j'ai défendue comme citoyen comme
candidat à l'élection présidentielle à
chaque élection présidentielle où j'ai
proposé un projet pour les Français
c'est il y avait cette idée que au bout
du compte
si l'on
si chaque Français a le sentiment que
cette réforme ou à la certitude que
cette réforme elle n'est pas faite pour
des intérêts du gouvernement ni pour des
intérêts de la majorité ni pour des
intérêts idéologiques ni pour des
intérêts de classe elle est faite pour
sauver le système de retraite à ce
moment-là oui c'est une ça aurait été
une logique que qu'elle soit ainsi
proposée au référendum
d'abord parce que le gouvernement a le
droit d'avoir sa propre vision et pas la
mienne je je
pense que chacun prend sa responsabilité
je suis pour une société de
co-responsabilité alors je trouve que
entre le gouvernement qui a la
responsabilité de l'exécutif et qu'il
exerce je crois de la manière la plus
sérieuse possible entre le Président de
la République qui donne l'impulsion
et
un chef de partie un responsable de la
majorités
il y a des années que ce sujet
occupe bien entendu les conversations et
la réflexion des responsables de la
majorité il demeure que c'est le
gouvernement qui prend ses
responsabilités et si vous interrogez
tous les responsables politiques je me
mets de côté ils disent tous mais
référendum est sûr de le perdre moi je
ne le crois pas
ça pourrait être une porte de sortie si
d'aventure il y avait blocage du pays
est-ce que voilà le gouvernement
pourrait dire écoutez on vous a entendu
donc on soumet sa référendum est-ce que
ça peut être une
gouvernement on en est pas aux portes de
sortie on est même pas à la porte
d'entrée
donc on va avoir un débat parlementaire
on va avoir sûrement des tensions dans
le pays alors justement monsieur Byron
de confrontation la porte d'entrée pour
le pour reprendre votre énergie d'autres
étapes sur lesquelles on reviendra la
porte d'entrée il y a déjà du monde
devant donc les Français nous l'avons
évoqué Benjamin et les Français et les
syndicats oui pour la première fois
depuis 12 ans le front syndical est uni
malgré les les semaines les mois de
concertation ça veut dire que ça n'a
servi à rien même les les semaines
supplémentaires que vous avez et que
vous aviez appelé de vos vœux au mois
d'octobre ça n'a servi à rien tous les
syndicats sont contre je ne crois pas du
tout ça quoi exactement le contraire je
vais essayer de vous le montrer ça a
servi à deux choses ou à deux éléments
essentiels
à mon sens aurait pu servir à trois
parce que c'est trois ou quatre mois
supplémentaires que en effet j'avais
proposé
et qui ont été décidées ils ont servi
d'abord à une à des concertations
approfondies les discussions
approfondies avec les syndicats sur des
sujets essentiels les carrières longues
la pénibilité on reviendra sûrement sur
ces sur ces aspects là et tous les
syndicats sans exception on dit que ça
avait été utile mais les positions n'ont
pas changé
les positions n'ont pas changé sur l'âge
mais sur la réforme mais ce projet
est un projet qui est beaucoup plus
large que l'âge et il faudra d'ailleurs
qu'il soit dans la réalité
laissez-moi aller au bout j'ai dit trois
éléments 1 les concertations les
discussions qui ont eu avec des
syndicats 2
probablement l'élément le plus important
on a évité le risque incroyable pour moi
insupportable qui était que les Français
le sentiment que dans une réforme
dissimulée brutale
à la sauvette par un amendement déposé
un soir on se mettait dans la situation
de prendre à revers ou de prendre par
surprise l'opinion ça à mon sens ça
aurait été une rupture de ce
de ce contrat de confiance démocratique
dont on a besoin une troisième chose qui
aurait pu être
cultiver à cette occasion c'est de faire
cette pédagogie profonde avec les avec
les chiffres précis les données précises
les éléments précis de démographie vous
trouverez aussi pour ce que ça intéresse
le rapport sur la démographie du plan
je dis à tous ceux que ça intéresse les
rapports sur les chiffres que j'ai donné
sur les retraites aussi bien que sur la
démographie vous allez sur plan.fr et
vous allez avoir tous ces rapports
précis on va y revenir mais pour
reparler des discussions avec les
syndicats notamment pendant ce mois de
délai que c'était octroyé le
gouvernement l'exécutif avait tout misé
sur la CFDT en disant bon bah malgré un
désaccord sur l'âge Laurent Berger va
quand même saluer des avancées c'est pas
le cas il a redit
ce deal qu'est-ce qui n'a pas marché
alors un mot sur un mot
ce jeudi avec les animaux sur la
démocratie sociale
moi je considère que le projet
de la France le projet républicain
démocratique
du pays impose un dialogue avec les
organisations syndicales et une
organisation du pays
qui prend en compte ce dialogue là je
considère pas du tout les syndicats
comme des emmerdeurs
parfois
ils prennent des décisions que je peux
pas approuver ce qui s'est passé à Noël
avec le blocage des trains et qui est
empêché un très grand nombre de gens et
de gens seuls
d'aller voir leur famille j'ai trouvé
que ça n'était pas juste
les contrôleurs
si on avait une démocratie sociale qui
fonctionne ce type de dysfonctionnement
ne serait ne serait pas arrivé donc mais
sur le fond et en règle générale je
considère qu'une organisation syndicale
une organisation des syndicats est utile
à l'intérieur de cette organisation des
syndicats il y a
à l'intérieur il y a il y a une
sensibilité qui est très importante
selon moi pour l'avenir du pays c'est ce
qu'on appelle les réformistes ceux qui
pensent
appartient à cette sensibilité là par
moment et selon les selon les sections
d'autres syndicats peuvent être de cette
sensibilité là une sensibilité qui pense
que on n'est pas obligé de tout résoudre
par l'affrontement et le congé
pardon là ils appellent tous à
l'affrontement et au conflits ils
appellent tous au blocage et ils
exhortent les Français à descendant la
rue ils espèrent un million de personnes
comme en 95 vous en souvenez vous étiez
ministre de l'éducation dans le
gouvernement à cette époque en 95 Juppé
il avait reculé est-ce que vous pensez
qu'on va avoir la même situation je
pense que le la mobilisation
c'est dans l'ordre des choses quand vous
avez des grands sujets qui sur lesquels
il y a des désaccords c'est dans leur
des choses vous avez employé un mot qui
n'est pas juste ah vous avez dit ils
appellent tous à bloquer le pays c'est
pas vrai personne
ils appellent à une journée d'action
avec des grèves et donc avec des
blocages
ils veulent que le mouvement soit
durable et ils veulent qu'ils durent
jusqu'au retrait du texte c'est c'est
comme ça qu'une société démocratique
fonctionne alors est-ce que c'est fondé
c'est ça la question et c'est pourquoi
je plaide pour cette pédagogie mais les
mêmes serments qu'en 95 je rappelle une
nouvelle fois vous étiez au gouvernement
donc vous vous étiez aux affaires vous
souvenez bien ce qui s'est passé est-ce
que vous voyez les mêmes éléments est-ce
que vous présentez les mêmes choses
pas vraiment
il y a une différence essentielle c'est
que en 1995 comme vous en souvenez
Jacques Chirac avait été élu sur le
thème de la fracture sociale
dans sur le thème de l'attention à ces
difficultés que les gens rencontraient
dans leur vie ici Emmanuel Macron a été
élu en affichant clairement qu'il y
avait une réforme des retraites
indispensables et il avait même avancé
65 ans ça n'est pas la même chose et
puis qu'est-ce que comment je peux dire
ça
je pense que dans les traits font de la
société
l'idée que
comme on vit plus longtemps comme il va
y avoir moins de gens qui vont
travailler en raison de la démographie
et que les retraites prennent une part
très importante de la production
nationale
alors forcément il faudra qu'on trouve
un nouvel équilibre monsieur je crois
que cette idée a diffusé même si je
répète les éléments précis n'ont jamais
été donnés
à la société aux citoyens dans leur
ensemble rapidement quand Olivier Vérand
explique je cite que l'exécutif ne se
projette pas dans l'idée d'une
mobilisation massive est-ce qu'il y a un
peu d'excès de confiance du côté du
gouvernement je suis pas là pour faire
le censeur des déclarations des uns et
des autres les Français seraient
résignés
dans ma bouche la même déclaration je
pense que que ce sont de grands sujets
parce qu'ils ne touchent pas seulement
à des décisions générales il touche à
des décisions qui ont un impact sur la
vie de alors justement un exemple
concret en raison pour laquelle on peut
je les dis réfléchir à des améliorations
ou à des précisions sur le texte sur les
petites retraites inquiétudes ce matin
traduite par Aurélien Pradier député les
républicains ils ont fait d'ailleurs une
ligne rouge les pensions minimales et la
revalorisation des petites retraites je
précise à ce sujet que 1200 euros brut
le chiffre qui est donné ce n'est pas
pour tout le monde c'est pour tout le
monde à taux plein donc les gens qui
n'ont pas le taux plein de cotisations
ils n'auront pas de 1200 euros il y aura
une re-valorisation mais elle ne sera
pas de l'ordre de 1200 euros brut à la
fin est-ce que sur les petites retraites
le gouvernement on fait assez est assez
précis est assez concret
il y a des il y a des précisions à
apporter la date le financement le le la
prise en compte le la différence combien
représente en net
1200 euros brut ça fait 1150 à peu près
quelque chose de cet ordre
bon ce sont des ce sont des précisions à
apporter je crois que la période qui
s'ouvre doit être utile de ce point de
vue là et elle va alors comme vous savez
elle aurait dû être utile dans un débat
à l'Assemblée nationale parce que c'est
les trois semaines
qui vont être prises à l'Assemblée
nationale aurait dû donner à des donner
lieu à des discussions approfondies sur
chacun de ces points il se trouve que
une partie des oppositions a décidé de
bloquer le débat de bloquer l'Assemblée
nationale moi je trouve que c'est une
mauvaise idée je vois très bien pourquoi
ils le font s'appelle de la flibuste du
Flibus string en anglais
c'est absolument classique on mobilise
tous les artifices et notamment le dépôt
de dizaines de milliers d'amendements
comme il faut 5 minutes par amendement
et le gouvernement a décidé de craindre
le temps maximum dans un texte
budgétaire donc utilisation 49-3
possible du gouvernement c'est la
Constitution
et on revient en direct dans un instant
tradition cette année dans l'émission je
vous montrerai trois photos également au
retour de pub idachète que photos il y a
une question d'actualité BFM politique
avec François baroquet notre invitation
comme d'habitude à 12h30 monsieur
bayrouge et faire apparaître trois
photos la dernière fois il y a une
question liée à l'actualité vous allez
voir apparaître le palais de l'Elysée
des trottinettes et le portrait de Noël
le Great quel première photo choisissez
vous
c'est vous qui choisissez ah non c'est
vous c'est ça le concept le palais de
l'Élysée qu'est-ce que vous voulez me
demander sur le palais il y a un proche
du pouvoir citant la presse cette
semaine qui estime que vous préparez le
site votre couple pour 2027 est-ce que
vous y pensez toujours à la présidence
de la République si il y a un seul
responsable politique qui ne pense pas à
l'élection majeure ce qui est on se
demande ce qui fait dans ce dans cet
engagement dans ce jeu
c'est là que vous savez bien que tout se
joue est-ce que c'est pour moi à titre
personnel une obsession de chaque matin
non
est-ce que cela dit c'est une c'est une
engagement écartée non
j'ai été candidat trop jeune à certaines
époques
à la présidence de la République on a
même failli réaliser ce qui a été
réalisé en 2017 avec Emmanuel Macron on
a failli le réaliser en 2007
je suis pleinement engagé dans la
question de l'avenir du pays
le bon âge éventuellement 2027 vous
dites j'étais trop jeune on va dire que
oui vous savez bien aujourd'hui si vous
regardez tous les pays du monde sans
quasiment qu'une exception
tous ont des présidents de la République
qui sont
ou du même âge ou plus âgé que moi Lula
vient d'être élu au Brésil il est comme
vous savez d'une génération un peu
antérieure à la mienne savoir optimiste
et non c'est pas ça la question
la question est ce que vous avez le
sentiment que la vision que vous avez
peut être
utile à une nouvelle étape du pays
utile
une fonction
utile dans un engagement
j'ai toujours eu ce sentiment et ça veut
dire que là c'est un trou de souris vous
irez non je parle je parle pas comme ça
parce que ça c'est l'obsession c'est
c'est dire mais voyons comment on va
faire pour dégager je n'ai pas cette
obsession mais vous n'exclez un nouveau
candidat à la présidence de la
République je n'excuse jamais rien il
nous reste deux photos monsieur Bayero
des trottinettes et Noël le gratte dans
cet ordre les trottinettes moi je suis
comme tout le monde je trouve ça parfois
ou souvent extrêmement agaçant
une votation sur les trottinettes donc
en libre-service elle souhaite faut dire
les choses elle le dit elle-même elle
souhaite les voir disparaître vous êtes
vous-même d'une ville est-ce que vous
êtes pour ou contre ces trottinette en
libre service
nous n'avons pas à
et vous souhaitez pas que ça arrive
c'est un début de réponse
allez reprenons le film nos échanges si
vous voulez bien sur les retraites cette
réforme qui est qui arrive parmi les
pistes que vous avez avancées vous dans
le débat il y avait l'augmentation des
cotisations patronales le gouvernement
vous répond claire net ça casserait
l'emploi
oui je crois pas
je vais essayer de vous le montrer
d'abord c'est un geste
qui montrerait qu'on sort du cycle
infernal dans lequel on est engagé
des retraites payées par les générations
futures
c'est quand même un truc complètement
dingue vous vous arrêtez une seconde
vous dites
il y a des choses qu'on peut partager
avec les générations futures si vous
construisez une université un hôpital
des écoles c'est légitime des réseaux
routiers ou ferroviaires il est légitime
de le partager avec les générations
futures c'est à dire d'emprunter et
qu'on répartisse la charge sur les
générations futures parce que elles vont
s'en servir mais faire payer les
retraites d'aujourd'hui
par ceux qui
sont au début de leur carrière dans 10
ans dans 20 ans et leur maître cette
charge sur le dos pour moi c'est
moralement
inacceptable et donc il faut il faut
sortir de ce cycle là donc on est dans
des entreprises de payer c'est la raison
pour laquelle ce que je plaide c'est
qu'on est un plan de retour progressif à
l'équilibre pas seulement l'effacement
des déficits futurs ce qu'on est en
train de faire déjà pas mal
mais l'effacement des déficits actuels
aussi donc dans un plan progressif et ce
plan progressif comme on peut faire pour
y arriver un arme principale c'est le
plein emploi pour ça que le gouvernement
a raison de travailler sur ce sujet
deuxièmement des progrès de productivité
pour le pays c'est très important aussi
et plus de personnes au travail et
notamment que les seniors ne soient pas
éjectés du travail on n'est pas bon sur
le sujet on est on est les derniers donc
donc très gros travail mais et si une
participation modeste des entreprises
peut donner aux Français le sentiment de
justice sur ses affaires là pourquoi le
gouvernement
on a droit des différences et vous
espérez
je vous dis une chose qu'est-ce que ça
représente
les retraites les cotisations des
entreprises sur les retraites c'est
16,5% du salaire de la masse salariale
mais il y a aussi
tout ce qui touche à la sécurité sociale
toutes ces ce qui veut dire que cette
partie cette augmentation de 1% des
cotisations patronales ça doit
représenter 0,5 06
07% d'une masse salariale qui va
augmenter cette année de 5%. c'est le ça
serait le dixième de l'augmentation de
la masse salariale cette année je ne
considère pas que ce soit
un attentat contre l'avenir du pays
l'avenir des entreprises l'économie je
pense que c'est un des moyens j'en ai
cité 4 ou 5 devant vous un des moyens de
revenir à un équilibre progressif du
système de retraite un état actuel des
choses dans la copie du gouvernement
certains devront travailler 44 ans
contre 43 ans pour les autres les
républicains demandent à ce que ce soit
corrigé dans le texte est-ce que c'est
votre avis aussi
intéressant qui est un débat qui a un
débat parlementaire il y a encore une
idée qui est sans doute intéressante
dans ces dans ces débats c'est qu'on est
un point de rendez-vous dans plusieurs
années ce qu'on appelle
un très joli une clause de revoyure
c'est-à-dire on dit dans quatre ans on
fera le bilan on verra où on en est et
du coup est-ce que c'est comme les
chiffres que je vous donne tous les 5
ans à la fin que les Français se
retrouvent tous les 5 ans inquiets c'est
une question très intéressante
là encore c'est une idée minoritaire
mais je défends des idées minoritaires
assez souvent avec l'idée que une idée
minoritaire peut se retrouver
majoritaire un jour et que la plupart du
temps si vous voulez devenir majoritaire
il faut commencer minoritaire
je pense qu'il faudrait trouver une
nouvelle gouvernance de notre système de
retraite ça n'est pas normal qu'on aille
de crise en crise de crispation
crispation d'affrontement en
affrontement je le répète alors qu'il
s'agit d'un sujet d'intérêt général donc
ça veut dire par exemple on aura un
exemple un système qui évolue seul on
dirait tous les 10 ans on augmente
quasiment en continu je vais prendre un
exemple ce système il existe pour les
retraites du privé qui elles sont
équilibrées je dis ça au passage parce
que on fait comme si
l'agir Carco a un conseil
d'administration entre les mains des
partenaires sociaux
et là ils ont pas fait grève ils ont
pris les décisions nécessaires les
syndicats
ont pris ensemble
avec le patronat les décisions
nécessaires pour que le régime de
retraite du privé soit équilibré vous
trouvez pas que ça que ça met au milieu
de la table un modèle qui mérite qu'on
s'y arrête une seconde vous êtes dans
une situation dans laquelle on est
incapable de faire une réforme mais les
principaux acteurs de la démocratie
sociale eux en situation de
responsabilité on fait ces réformes-là
sur la question François vairaud de
cette réforme on voit qu'il y a un deal
qui est en train de commander qui est
annoncé entre le gouvernement et les
républicains ils ont été reçus à
plusieurs reprises par Elisabeth borne
c'est quoi c'est la réforme ericciotique
comme le disent les républicains est-ce
que ça vous ça vous agace qui est ce
voilà cet accord et que tout cela penche
clairement à droite ça c'est quand vous
êtes dans le bocal politique
vous êtes dans l'occurrence
dans le texte plus ou moins et de
de plus en plus éloigné de du bocal
c'est ça le privé le privilège de
l'expérience dont vous dont vous parliez
à l'instant
quand vous êtes dans le bocal politique
vous dites mais voyons le gain est pour
qui
mais vous vous rendez pas compte que la
société française tout entière se fout
de sa voix pardon de
la vulgarité de mon expression se fiche
de savoir
pour qui est le gain non mais vous qui
prenez donc prenez le dépassement des
clivages ça ne vous pose pas de problème
que il est un accord entre le
gouvernement et la droite sur ce sujet
question c'est simple
j'espère que d'autres vont s'y
intéresser vous dites vous avez prenez
le dépassement des clivages on y est
et ça dans le sillage du scandale ORPEA
a une charge assez lourde dans le
Journal du Dimanche aujourd'hui le
détail sera donc publié demain ce que
vous partagez son constat est-ce qu'on
n'a pas fait assez pour nos aînés
pas vraiment
je parle comme mère d'une ville
importante dans laquelle il y a
évidemment des EHPAD et des EHPAD
municipaux
qui marchent très bien et qui sont à
très bas prix et qui sont d'un très haut
niveau de service
et
pour quelque chose comme 50 euros par
jour c'est dire que que ce sont des prix
extrêmement bas
je pense qu'il y a des choses
formidables qui se font dans les EHPAD
et que la manière de cibler que les
médias utilisent parce que c'est le
c'est la règle du jeu médiatique la
manière de cibler ces
organisations et ces femmes et ses
hommes qui sont associatifs parfois qui
sont municipales qui sont d'intérêt
général
et aussi il y a des il y a des
établissements qui sont aussi très bien
dans ces systèmes là
qu'il y ait des excès alors il faut s'en
prendre à ceux qui laissent faire ces
excès parce que il n'est pas possible
que ces excès n'est pas été montrés
signalées et bien il faut regarder si on
peut indiquer des manières de faire et
des manières de vérifier la vie dans ces
établissements mais ils sont
indispensables ces établissements
indispensables
il faudra inventer nous sommes en train
de préparer aux plans une étude qui va
sortir dans les jours qui viennent sur
le vieillissement de la population il
faudra préparer d'autres approches que
les EHPAD il y a beaucoup d'innovations
à trouver dans ce système
et beaucoup de progrès à faire mais je
ne veux pas jeter la pierre à l'ensemble
des EHPAD sous prétexte de dérive
indiscutable et inacceptable autre sujet
dramatique mais minoritaire autre sujet
dramatique cette cette semaine le
suicide d'un jeune garçon Lucas il avait
13 ans il est effectivement d'homophobie
il avait déclaré son homosexualité assez
à ses parents ses camarades de classe
lui en ont fait
payer un prix terrible il a décidé de
mettre fin à ses jours le harcèlement
scolaire c'est un fléau vous avez été
ministre de l'Éducation je le rappelle
comment on sort de ça il y a Lucas 13
ans je pourrais vous citer ambre 11 ans
qui a mis fin à un séjour le jour de
Noël et il y a malheureusement trop
beaucoup trop d'enfants qui décident en
terminer pour ces raisons
[Musique]
le harcèlement scolaire c'est une des
choses les plus dégueulasses qu'on
puisse rencontrer
et on ne peut lutter que par une alerte
perpétuelle et une
une éducation morale
pardon employé des mots qui s'utilise
plus
depuis des années je suis obsédé par la
question de la solitude
on est une société avec des réseaux
sociaux innombrables
où tout le monde semble connecter à tout
le monde et en réalité probablement
jamais la solitude n'a été aussi
importante et c'est la même solitude à
tous les moments de la vie
les personnes âgées
les couples qui explosent le chômage
l'entrée à l'université c'est autant
d'occasions de solitude nous avons monté
à Pau un plan antisolitude depuis déjà 5
ans où on s'efforce d'aller chercher à
leur domicile les personnes et la
solitude de la cour de récréation c'est
la même solitude
il y avait beaucoup de camarades qui
avaient vu
peut-être beaucoup de camarades qui
avaient participé
qui a expliqué à ses enfants que quand
on voit il faut dire
est-ce que les médias eux-mêmes le font
c'est pas pour vous mettre en cause
ça dépend comment vous le faites comment
les médias en général le font comment
les réseaux sociaux le font
il y a une camarade de Lucas qui disait
on n'a pas vu qu'il n'allait pas bien on
a cru qu'il allait mieux et on n'avait
pas vu qu'il allait qu'il avait
replonger ça pose aussi la question du
suivi et de l'accompagnement et
ces drames quel que soit l'âge on
retrouve toujours les mêmes remarques
mais est-ce que ça veut dire que il
allait mieux on croyait qu'il allait
mieux le fait d'avoir fait évoluer la
loi en 2022 donc en fait désormais il y
a des peines d'emprisonnement il y a des
amendes qui sont possibles je rappelle
que pour un enfant le discernement est
considéré comme de toute façon aboli
avant 13 ans sauf si on arrive à
démontrer l'inverse et peut-être
pénalement responsable mais uniquement
dans certaines conditions ça plus les
numéros verts qui sont mis en place 38
en 19 30 20 bon les gouvernements
successifs essaient mais force est de
constater qu'ils échouent pour l'instant
si vous croyez que la vie est facile
c'est parce que je dis et qu'il est
facile de décider que les que les
comportements terribles on va les
changer parce qu'on aura changé un texte
c'est beaucoup plus profond que ça et
c'est pourquoi je parle d'éducation
morale donc ça doit se passer à l'école
cette éducation morale dans la famille
les familles qui me sur les écrans ils
passent leur vie sur les écrans
et au lieu de de pousser comme on le dit
des publicités
pour tout un tas de choses qui les
ciblent si on avait une action publique
les publicitaires pourraient participer
les médias pour y participer les réseaux
sociaux pour y participer en disant que
quand on voit on dit
quand on voit on dit parce que au bout
du compte
il y a le pire de ce qui peut arriver en
tout cas
je trouve que d'une certaine manière
dire faut faire un texte de plus c'est
se débarrasser du sujet nous allons
rester à l'école d'une autre manière
Benjamin oui on a vu cette semaine
revenir le débat autour de l'uniforme
obligatoire à l'école une proposition de
loi rassemblement national a été rejetée
jeudi la première dame Brigitte Macron a
surpris en si déclarant favorable dans
les colonnes du Parisien vous avez
plusieurs fois dit que vous y étiez
favorable notamment en 2006 est-ce que
c'est toujours le cas est-ce que vous
êtes favorable à l'uniforme obligatoire
à l'école
je peux vous faire une confidence
allez-y
toute ma vie j'ai rêvé de créer une
école je n'ai pas fait parce que j'étais
c'était un peu un peu lourd et que ma
famille parfois pense que j'en fais déjà
assez sur des tas de sujets et que d'une
certaine manière c'est à leur dépend
j'aurais mis un uniforme dans cette
école
mais l'uniforme c'est pas une tradition
française
il y a des gens qui disent autrefois il
y avait des uniformes c'est pas vrai il
y a une blouse une blouse qui est pas
tout à fait l'uniforme mais dans les
autres mères les uniformes obligatoires
oui parce que
la tradition anglo-saxonne
qui est formidable qui est formidable le
j'ai des souvenirs précis dans les
bidonvilles de Mumbai de voir des gamins
pieds nus en uniforme chic des petites
filles et des petits garçons d'école
primaire
c'est un signe d'appartenance et de
valorisation mais je ne pense pas qu'on
puisse l'imposer du sommet
je pense que les conseils d'école
doivent s'en saisir
c'est à eux de discuter on verra des
expériences
en tout cas ça veut dire quelque chose
de très important
au-delà du sujet de l'uniforme c'est le
débat sur l'uniforme le débat sur
l'uniforme il dit quelque chose c'est
qu'il y a un besoin d'ordre dans la
société et dans ce il y a un besoin de
de reprendre le contrôle dans ce débat
certains au sein de la majorité étaient
favorables ce sont dit favorables
justement au port de l'uniforme et
pourtant ils n'ont pas voté la
proposition de loi du rassemblement
national est-ce que c'est pas un peu
hypocrite Marine Le Pen elle dit et ben
c'est la preuve de leur sectarisme
c'est des jeux parlementaires je comme
vous avez vu j'ai pas l'intention
d'entrer là dedans mais je pense que
ça dit quelque chose d'une attente
profonde de la société dans laquelle on
est je vais vous dire une chose de plus
sur l'uniforme
ce qui me plaît d'ailleurs vous avez dit
que je m'étais prononcé autrefois sur le
sujet ce qui est insupportable c'est la
tyrannie des marques
et la tyrannie des marques précisément
chez les enfants qui sont dans des
familles qui n'ont pas les moyens
et qui et qui croit trouver et qui je
connais des exemples ou
il martyrise leurs parents leur mère
c'est parfois des mères seuls souvent
des mères seuls pour trouver une
reconnaissance il passe par les marques
et là encore la question de la
reconnaissance qui passe pas par
l'argent est une question
vitale de la société dans laquelle on
est Monsieur Berrou Adrien Catena s'est
revenu à l'Assemblée nationale
au mois de décembre vous dénonciez sous
avis appelé une chasse à l'homme vous
disiez moi
à la chasse à l'homme qu'est-ce que vous
dites aujourd'hui est-ce que vous êtes à
l'aise avec l'idée qu'Adrien catenens je
rappelle était condamné pour avoir giflé
son épouse revienne sur le bon Assemblée
nationale
c'est sa conduite avec laquelle je suis
pas à l'aise ce genre de
d'explosion je suis pas à l'aise avec
simplement focaliser tout le débat
autour de ça alors
est-ce qu'il a sa place sur les bancs de
l'Assemblée en fait est-ce que la loi
lui donne sa place sur les bancs de la
santé rien ne le pousse à démissionner
et donc et donc de ce point de vue là on
peut avoir des discussions de de
préférence mais du point de vue de la
loi il a le droit de siéger justement du
point de vue de la loi le groupe
Renaissance et Aurore berger souhaite
déposer une proposition de loi comment
dire rendant visant à créer une peine
d'inelligibilité pour les élus reconnus
coupables de certaines violences
notamment
en l'état non le juge le juge a toujours
le droit s'il voit des syllabes à juger
de comportement extrêmement lourd alors
je sais pas si dans ce cas c'est prévu
mais le juge a toujours le droit
d'ajouter une peine
si vous êtes quelques années pour ce
type de violence entre familiale vous ne
pouvez plus être élu est-ce que vous
êtes favorable à ce type de proposition
j'aime pas trop les règles générales
comme ça qui sont qui sont lancés en
peinture je trouve que je trouve que le
discernement du juge
c'est une garantie de liberté pour les
citoyens je n'aime pas l'automaticité
des sanctions et d'ailleurs à mon avis
elles sont pas constitutionnels en
parlant de l'automaticité des sanctions
monsieur bayraud projet loi immigration
on a beaucoup parlé des retraites c'est
un autre texte très très important qui
va arriver très important au 1er février
et dans ce texte entre autres Gérald
Darmanin prône le retour de la double
peine est-ce que c'est quelque chose que
vous soutenez auquel vous êtes favorable
on va avoir des bases je n'y suis pas
opposé
c'est pas ça veut pas dire je soutiens
pleinement ça oui j'ai pas dit que je
tenais pleinement je vous dites ça il
prône dans quelles conditions pour
qu'elle peine j'ai besoin de regarder ça
mais vous voyez bien le
sur des sujets aussi difficiles que cela
la situation où les
conséquences directes de peine qui ne
sont pas appliquées
de décision qui ne sont pas respectées
et qui font que régulièrement en
première page de vos journaux on
retrouve
un crime un attentat des choses
insupportables par des individus des
personnes qui auraient dû être écartées
c'est insupportable pour la société
regardez c'est insupportable mais c'est
aussi incompréhensible et je poursuis
l'exemple que vous donnez à l'instant
l'agresseur de la Gare du Nord c'est
très récent cet homme est libyen il est
visé par une occultée une obligation de
quitter le territoire français sauf
qu'il est libyen de fait il ne peut pas
être renvoyé en Libye par la situation
de son pays or l'occulté fait tout de
même prononcé
il y a un problème
comme vous dites alors est-ce qu'il est
légitime de ne pas renvoyer des gens
simplement parce que leur pays est dans
un état de désordre absolu c'est une
question qu'on a le droit de poser
ouvertement
oui je trouve que je trouve que la
situation actuelle n'est pas supportable
pour un très grand nombre de Français
qui disent mais enfin comment c'est
possible le 11 on se souvient du du
drame dans le Nord enfin de
oui on a on a raison de poser ce genre
de questions certains au sein de la
majorité poussent une phrase de plus
quand l'acide si on est d'accord pour
dire que la situation actuelle n'est pas
acceptable alors il faut pas l'accepter
oui une question monsieur beyrus sur un
des combats politiques de votre vie à
savoir la proportionnel je dis le
rassemblement national a proposé là
encore et bien l'instauration de la
proportionnelle intégrale
tous les députés de la majorité les
députés modem de votre groupe s'ils sont
opposés comment est-ce qu'on peut pas se
faire comme ça vous voyez bien que c'est
parce que ça vient du rassemblement
national non c'est parce que
mes amis savent que j'ai toujours
plaider contre une démarche il y en a
plusieurs ici une démarche subreptise
sur ces sujets à l'emporte-pièce on va
déposer un texte par surprise il va être
adopté toujours été contre ça ne peut
venir que d'un débat approfondie sur la
démocratie que nous voulons je suis pour
que notre démocratie intègre
automatiquement le pluralisme jusqu'à
maintenant sauf lors de la dernière
élection le pluralisme était banni de
nos institutions
ça n'est pas acceptable
c'est pas comme ça qu'on avance et vous
votez contre et bien il aura l'occasion
je l'espère d'avoir le débat trans
partisan que le premier ministre que le
Président de la République a promis dont
il va si je suis bien informé proposer
les cadres dans les semaines qui
viennent vous aimeriez après les
retraites que le chantier des
institutions soit engagé et que par
exemple la proportionnelle intégrale
soit mise en oeuvre qui a certains
nombre de réformes Stéphane séjourné
parlaient du de la question du septennat
est-ce que vous aimeriez que ce soit le
prochain chantier après la réforme des
retraites alors le septena je serai
contre pour des raisons que je vous
expliquerai quand vous m'interrogerez à
la mission quand vous m'interrogerez sur
ce sujet là mais le pluralisme dans nos
institutions avec la spécificité
française notre chance c'est qu'on a
un président de la République qui permet
que ça marche et on peut avoir une
assemblée
Parlement qui garantissent le plus
réaliste pas voir les deux simplement il
faut tout réapprendre par exemple je
suis ce là encore minoritaire qui pense
qu'il faut changer le mode de
fonctionnement de l'Assemblée nationale
alors on me dit c'est impossible on me
dit toujours que c'est impossible pour
l'instant en tout cas mais je suis pour
que on est plus cette
galopade dans les couloirs pour aller
voter ou ne pas voter sans avoir
participé au débat je suis que comme au
Parlement européen on puisse examiner
plusieurs textes en même temps et qu'on
vote toujours en présence toujours en
scrutin public sur tous les textes et
tous les amendements comme ça on a plus
le et
[Musique]